he won bronze at in the games in South
Korea and you will be able to see him in
the 2018 Stars on Ice tour that starts
in Fort Myers Florida on April 6th and
runs all the way through to May 20th in
the beautiful city of Portland Oregon
you can get your tickets at stars on ice
dot-com right now he is Adam rip on good
to see you sir
good to be here how's life life is good
you know rich just living it up mm-hmm
I'm here talking about clown makeup yes
you just talk to this clown makeup with
Chris Brockman yes okay Oh bucket list
bucket list right there Adam yeah for me
yeah for me to be here and experience
that how has life changed for you you
know in a way it really hasn't changed
at all come on
well on the flip side of that it's
completely and totally different I feel
like I've really tried to just kind of
still be me still you know have fun with
everything that I'm doing but at the
same time what is different it's like oh
okay I'm going on Ellen again and I'm
doing this and I'm doing that and I have
like a full schedule of doing a bunch of
things and they don't really involve
skating anymore which has been the
craziest part is that good is that what
you want
I think so yes it is what I want I think
that for a really long time I always
loved making people laugh and I've
always been like a performer at heart
okay and I've always channeled that into
my skating and while I was at the
Olympics I saw and had the chance to do
all of these interviews and talk with so
many different people and I was like I
really enjoy doing this and I was almost
like I feel more comfortable doing this
than I do even competing I feel more in
control like more in the driver's seat
what to be honest with you odd since you
are in an individual sport and I mean
you keep I mean you can unless you think
that there's some sort of in skating god
that looks down that thinks that maybe
you should fall here or not hit
something I mean if you know the skating
god I wish you would have called him a
few years ago I don't I don't know if
there is one I would not know but you
know what it's skating is such a
challenging sport but I think it sets
you up for success later in life
it is so easy to just get into your head
where you really need to put so many
things out of your mind because you
can't overpower anything that you're
doing
you can't under do anything that you're
doing or all goes awry and it it's all
off at the Olympics I don't think I've
ever been more nervous for anything in
my entire life I never wanted to throw
up and have diarrhea at the same time
are you sure about that Adam I mean
let's go back throughout life you know
sure about me I go and I don't I don't
mean to you know bring up any yeah you
know well okay you know what I won't say
ever I'll say at least for a while I
think you said some that said something
about a xanax or something yeah I wanted
a xanax yeah I mean a little zani
wouldn't hurt anybody right so you were
that nervous I was going out there yes
you know there's a lot going on and um I
felt like even in Korea when you're at
the Olympics you're sort of in this
Olympic bubble where you don't really
have any idea of what is going on like
because of the village is that what you
mean yes and you know you just go and do
your practice you speak to the media you
go back to the village and then you do
the same thing and like later in the day
and you do that you know for a few days
here at the Olympics for three weeks so
you don't really know what's going on
but because of social media you have
like all of this interaction with like
the outside world and I could tell that
like what I was saying in the media was
getting picked up by a lot of oh yeah
yeah and I was like you know what I
really now more than ever
need to put my head down and back up my
big ol mouth with some good skating and
you know is the first time you know I
think in my whole entire life where I
was like I need to completely like check
out of this moment and go on autopilot
and you know it's just all that training
that kind of gets you through that
moment Adam rip on here on the Rich
Eisen show what of what you said do you
think was the thing that put the most
pressure on you to skate the skate I
think it was like the little
back-and-forth I had with mike pence
um I think if when I he reached out
before the opening ceremonies I was like
okay like I'm hearing from the
vice-president of the United States I
feel like there's like some eyes on me
now and I felt like it was really
important for you know everything that I
had been saying for me to back it up and
be like well I say what I'm thinking but
I want you to respect me because like
I've worked incredibly hard for this
moment and I showed up to represent the
United States to the best of my ability
which was being there as like my
authentic self which is being there well
trained and was being there to get my
team of metal so how how messy were your
mentions on Twitter did you check him
out
oh rich it wasn't pretty
it was messy I don't think I think what
was so what really took me back was that
um you know I got so many messages that
were overwhelmingly positive like you
know we're cheering for you but I
overwhelmingly on the flip side of that
got so many messages that I've never
cheered for an American to fall before
or I I hope you break your legs you
don't deserve to be there you should
just leave and I mean I'm 28 years old
I've been teased like all throughout
like my childhood so I kind of have a
thick skin it's gonna take more than
like an internet comment to really get
to me
but it's I just felt like you know
you're at the Olympics and you're
working your entire life for this moment
and does disrespectful did you ever meet
with the vice president I didn't know I
would but I don't think that he's really
looking forward to him you have to
excuse me for laughing on that I don't
know if you were being facetious or
funny or both mm-hmm facetiously funny
facetiously funny haha I had a rip on
here on the Rich Eisen show overall
Olympic experience was what how would
you describe I'm incredible it was
everything that I wanted it to be my
Olympic experience was incredible
I'm so fortunate that I didn't make the
team in 2010 or 2014 because when I did
make it this time around I had such a
greater respect for what I was doing I
was incredibly grateful to be there I
knew all of the hard work I had put in
all of the sacrifices I had made and I
went in and said I just want to really
enjoy the experience and I don't think I
could have enjoyed it or taken it in or
or done it any any better or differently
well just speaking on behalf of somebody
again my kids are on their way here to
meet you just they they they loved
getting to know you and meet you through
your skating and my wife and I meeting
you through your your demeanor and your
statements you got fans you got fans
everywhere well that means a lot thank
you the truth an absolute truth I want
to take a 60-second break and talk about
this tour a little bit we had Scott
Hamilton here yesterday I know I saw
that well skating royalty we are we are
all about the skating I love it
you know that's 2018 man just in Kate
you know you know we have a golf you
know putting green or right and you know
other you know he had some basketballs
but we're about this game yeah
cross-training yeah you know and then I
just want to know how how much time
would you get for somebody who's never
skated before for me to just do a single
toe loop or something like that don't
answer now okay I could guess your
answer right now yeah you're not even
looking at me
I can't we're back in 60 seconds with
Adam rip on Candice Parker also still to
come
[Music]
phantom rip on hanging out with us here
on the Rich Eisen show you are gonna be
packing your bags aren't you
I am I mean you were going all over
these United States of America
Fort Myers Orlando Fort Lauderdale
Providence Portland mm-hmm Portland and
Portland Maine and Oregon oh look at you
hey now anything any place named
Portland is gonna be I mean yeah on our
radar on your guitar and so who else is
gonna be on this tour stars ah nice calm
to get tickets so we have Olympic
champions Meryl Davis and Charlie White
we have the incredible Nathan Chen
Ashley Wagner the entire 2018 Olympic
team who is in the team event you know
we have a great cast it's gonna be an
incredible show and you know what you're
really getting everybody right off of
being in the best shape of their life so
they're we're ready okay
any advice for Nathan Chen after his
Olympic experience well you know I I
train with Nathan and after the
competition I just kind of like slapped
him a little bit um why because I
thought that he kind of he got in his
head and he has worked so hard but the
world championships are going on right
now and he's leading after the short
program and I think that's like the guy
that we always knew was there so the
free skate is I think tomorrow but so
I'll be cheering him on
so okay when did you first Adam rip on
here on on the show when did you first
realize you wanted to skate like this is
what you wanted to do or you were good
at it you really wanted to pursue it
well I'm from small town in Pennsylvania
and we get bitter winters and the
Scranton Scranton okay it's a good city
good people okay and not everybody back
[Music]
all right so scratched Scranton Chamber
of Commerce so we have like a lot of
minor league teams so we actually were
home with the wilkes-barre Scranton
Yankees and back in the day we had the
red barons okay so they would take the
Red Baron's feels and they'd flood it
and turned it into a rink in the winter
mm-hmm probably not good for the field
but it's good for skating good for me
and you would get out there and I'd get
out there every winter I would get out
there and I'd be like I'm gonna be
amazing and take three steps fall down
and tell my mom that I just wanted to
Swiss Miss hot chocolate and to like get
the hell out of there
and then finally one year I went to a
friend's birthday party and I had a lot
of fun I kept asking my mom to bring me
back to the rink
please bring me back please bring me
back and then as a birthday present for
me on my tenth birthday my mom signed me
up for the group classes and then ever
since that moment I just was hooked
that's it that's it and when did you
think that this might not happen for you
didn't how often that happen like every
day I think that when you're young and
you have this dream and a goal that you
have this blind confidence that you'll
you'll make it no and when I didn't make
the team in 2010 I felt like I'm still
young I was 19 20 I still have time my
time is in four years and then four
years later I skated terribly at like
our most important competition of the
qualifier and I was like I maybe I'm
never gonna go to the Olympics but I
think because of that like rock bottom I
was able to not only get better but be
better than I ever really thought I ever
was going to be and really come into my
own and Co go to this Olympic Games and
feel really confident in myself and and
what I was doing
yeah I mean we had Scott Hamilton
yesterday and all the things that he
said it was it was really inspiring and
and an occasion intense you know with
him battling cancer for as long as he
has him saying that he calculated that
he fell he fell at least 40 1600 times
in his career and he said the thing that
he likes about that the most is he got
up every time yeah
I mean their mics I mean I'm not good at
laughs that sounds like a lot of fallin
[Music]
damn Scott yeah did you get still fall
less yeah stand up maybe that should be
the name of his book fall Moscato less
Scott Hamilton foreword by Adam Ripon
yeah I don't know if that'll sell a lot
of books probably what I mean is that
does that resonate with you that that's
a whole sensation totally I think that
as an athlete and like as a human being
we sometimes I am a human being rich yes
first Formula that's that laugh was just
about the whole fall us Scottsdale
you're still there you're sometime come
with me come with me and this
conversation I'm with you I'm with you
you're drifting man you're thinking
about Michigan I need to stay in my lane
I think the thing about sports is that
sometimes we limit ourselves where we
don't want to make mistakes and we try
to stay within this realm of an of an
emotion or a feeling that we feel like
we can control and I have learned
through making many mistakes that it's
not embarrassing and that if you don't
even give yourself a chance to try or if
you don't give 100% you'll always walk
away and have regrets but if you fell
short and you gave yourself one and you
put 100% into whatever you were doing
you can learn from that and you can
learn okay I can make this better the
next time but I didn't hold back and I
think that what I've learned was that I
always walked away and was disappointed
in myself when I held back and I learned
that there's no shame in making mistakes
but I know that I will always walk away
and feel like a champion and feel like a
success if I gave 100% into every single
thing that I was doing and I rip on a
few more minutes with him here in
studios so are you done competing well
this was definitely my last Olympics
like I'm not joking any buddy mm people
are like we'll see you in four years and
I was like
maybe if I'm like on vacation um it
could be 32 I mean Tom Brady's doing it
in the NFL twitch I know he's that's so
good Tom good for you man yeah well you
know in skating on my team I was the
oldest first-time Olympian in figure
skating since the 1930s Daniel yeah I
did not know that fact I know oh you
were around then though I'm kidding I'm
not that oh no I am though when skating
and I was the oldest first-time Olympian
since the 1930s does I'm singing it
again cuz sometimes you were lagging
behind no no no no look I feel like you
feel like you should hand me flashcards
to keep up with you right now despite my
advancing years no I know you're quick
man but my teammates were 17 and 18 so
10 years older than they were we were
all at our first Olympics so are you
completely like pop culture out of their
universe that's what I'm saying I mean
you felt like the grandpa I did yeah I
did you know the kids at 17 know their
children I could have changed their
diapers could have so you did not then I
didn't confirm you did not change a diet
I'm here to confirm that I didn't change
a single diaper when I was in Korea okay
very good
so now that you are as you say you're
done with your Olympics what do you want
to do like if I could wave a wand and an
atom rip on gets to do well atom rip on
wants to do what is that what would you
want I love this show because a minute
ago you're talking about the gods and
you could talk to them so now I'm ready
for the wand we have a direct line we DM
we can DM yeah okay we could slide into
that tank yeah love that you know I
think what's so interesting right now is
I don't know exactly what that is right
but through this whole media tour that
I've been doing I've had such an
incredible opportunity to try out so
many different platforms as a guest yeah
I definitely love hosting and I want to
do something that feels like I can still
be myself and in
racked with people because I feel like I
really shine when I can chat and make
people laugh like really quickly as I've
been doing here you have I've been
trying since the first moment you have
you I saw that in your eyes actually
thousand percent on yeah so I don't know
exactly what that is yet so I'm trying
to actualize it I'm trying to walk
through every open door there is right
now and find out what that is how about
how about four words for you the atom
rip on shell what about that I love it
that's it that's it and rip the knob off
and then you know you could have a mug
with you as a silhouette of you skin you
know in the dressing room there's one of
you with blades on the body yes that was
the logo for our Super Bowl show in
Minnesota I loved it I took a college
the form what do you think of the form
if I got because I'm I'm dreadful with
on a pair of skates really yeah pretty I
felt like the form was all there
okay it was all there you seemed you
know it was just a silhouette yeah um
but I could tell that the way that your
stance was was that you knew exactly
what you were doing
yeah that's what it's called Photoshop
really yeah it's called photos Wow yeah
be honest with you all right
I've been avoiding I've been avoiding
this this but but just show it we could
show it my wife took this video of me
skating on vacation my Sun Valley right
we're in sunny yeah you know exactly
where we are
yes they do there we are Wow it's me and
the sunrise and shuffle in shorts by the
way what was the worst thing is those
were that old pair of swimming trunks
that my wife made me throw out because
they were just and you're like what
these are perfect these things my
costume pretty honey
I should put sequins on it yeah no you
were shining bright enough you didn't
eat a stone cold stones is that what
they're called yes well sis okay let me
like I'd let me educate you okay a
sequin is like those plastic things that
are like sequins okay and then what we
have on our costumes they're caught
they're stuck like stones they're called
crystals over there like so why say
denigrating the crystal well I'll get a
sequin
yeah did I really I don't derogatory I
didn't you take me for a cloud see the
atom rip on show I mean we're piloting
that right now I love it
thank you for coming on thank you for
you've got three kids who want to meet
you in the back hope one of them is for
one of them is for one of them is seven
and one of them is nine and they're all
very excited to meet you I can see eight
you you're doing that and doing this
show and good luck to you packing your
bags for star nice calm and I believe
I'm geographically sound for you where
you live here in Los Angeles here in the
studios yes
please come back I'd love to any time
Adam rip on at a DEA rip why aren't you
out what why is that you're the Adam rip
on was taken so it's a drop a few
letters you understand who you are now I
I understand so let's get the blue
checkmark lets who is that really is it
really an Adam rip on there is a video
game developer by the way is really
smart he's never tweeted by the way are
you serious are you serious yeah yeah
that's an outrage yeah which means I'm
glad he didn't check his mentions during
during the 11 yeah he's what break my
legs what did I do
thanks for coming on here yeah thank you
you got an atom rip on the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience